[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay pokemon world championship but then
I had a reality check I walked through
that extremely large
good morning it is the day after our
today see no filter show good morning
Mary we are going to the White House
right now what we um we got invited to
go to the White House to talk to some
very important people
no it's the Blazer who does that it's
all I got
oh look we got inside this guy they're
just like us what what what this is
bowling alley in the basin of the White
House Callie was created by harry s
truman who you don't if you don't know
it was our 290 v president he left a
bowl are you really giving me a
historical race do you think we've had
295 presidents
[Music]
we're post our meeting and bowling
we got apples from Michelle Obama's
office it tastes like really cut arms oh
now going in the airport a little Austin
I think the most excited person here is
just to see the immense to me I am just
worried you're doing great
[Music]
[Music]
what another day another airport I got
hot green tea because I'm
overcompensating on sophistication my
t-shirt says I'm 30 years old and I'm
wearing a blanket as a scarf I got my
travel she's down probably that watch
this guy's but he looked like while he
was making it the whole time great right
we're here at the beautiful Palace of
Fine Arts and Cisco photo show check out
our green room comes with one Chester C
and cheese Fanta
I don't again days let's see the stage I
haven't even seen it yet ready
so quite like the other part of the show
he'll ask you to paint it out and or say
something like this is right before the
show this is how I just meditate right
before the show what's happening good
morning
it is the day I'm sorry San Francisco
show we're here yeah getting healthy
because this Airport it's so healthy
that it makes you feel bad if you're not
we're getting ready to go back to Los
Angeles to our very last and Filter show
for tomorrow night if you haven't bought
your tickets please buy them already
except it might be sold out we're not
totally sure but try I wanted to quickly
at the end of this video let you guys
know that if you hadn't known already
there's merch available and represent
calm slash its grace you guys have been
wanting merch for a really long time
and it's here look it's a shirt with a
little pocket with the two bottles
holding hands and there's kind of gender
neutral if you're a color blind and the
goal was for 500 shirts to get sold so
that we could get them made and it's
already up to seven hundred thirty-one
shirts and that's awesome and there's
eighteen days left of the campaign so
make sure you go over to represent come
slash it's grace and get some merch the
shirts are really cute trust me I went
through a bunch of designs before
settling on this one and I like it and I
would wear it so but what does that tell
you about my design tastes I don't know